Ukrainian officials say that the Black
Sea port of Odessa has come under
Russian attack for the second night in a
row the regional Governor says that air
defense systems were engaged to repel
the airstrikes the port is a key route
for Ukraine's grain exports the latest
attacks come after Moscow pledged
retaliation following a blast on the
Kurt Kurt straight Bridge linking Russia
to Crimea residents have been urged to
stay in shelters
further in Ukraine's East battles are
intensifying as both sides trying to
break through the front lines Keith says
Russia is amassing 100 000 soldiers and
around 900 tanks assadbeg visited one
town to gauge how residents are coping
there's an eerie emptiness in seversk
the grass is overgrown straight animals
wander the streets
the buildings are burnt out shells of
what they were before the war thousands
of people used to live here few remains
this man tells us we receive aid but
every day they fire mortars I'm fed up
with it we hear the bang and four
seconds three seconds two seconds they
land despite the sounds of the shells
firing and Landing people gather to
enjoy what they can of the summer days
solution when the missiles hit we were
here where else would we be we saw the
two clouds rise from two locations
mushroom shape nobody was injured it was
just very powerful and everything shook
it's the little everyday things that
people hold on to here
I have a small gas stove and a small
canister that's how I heat the water I
put the coffee sugar and some special
spices cinnamon and has a good smell
soya says she doesn't want to leave
go to other parts of Ukraine that don't
see the war they say you're from dombas
this all happened because of you go back
to dombas why don't you flee elsewhere
but where should we flee some hostel I
live in my own flat my own from the edge
of town you can see less a chance
Russian forces took control of it in
July last year everything in between is
considered too dangerous to visit the
playground is empty There Are No
Children left and just like that the
afternoon peace is shattered gunfire can
be heard as Ukrainian soldiers attempt
to shoot down a drone when you visit
these towns and Villages along the front
line you ask yourself what's left of
these places yes they're a position on a
map and may hold some strategic
significance but most of the buildings
here have either been destroyed or
damaged and most people have left
foreign
and that gives you an idea of
what this place is going through there's
artillery strikes and there's drones up
in the air
and we can't leave until there's a lull
in the battle
because we don't want to become a Target
I said Big Al Jazeera it's a verse
eastern Ukraine